e aí
e a massa de um buraco negro desacelera
o tempo a tal ponto que em suas
fronteiras chamadas horizonte o tempo
permanece parado
e portanto para sair de um buraco negro
você precisa se mover em direção ao
presente e não em direção ao futuro
e se mover em direção ao presente
hoje pode parecer impossível mas a
sessão as palavras do carlos o velho um
físico italiano com quem eu aprendi a
ler o seu livro a ordem do tempo ao
enfrentar um evento massivo como que a
gente está vivendo no nosso planeta
agora a solução não está no esforço da
gente tentar prever o futuro se preparar
porque vamos encarar meses à frente eu
ainda nos próximos anos antes disso tá
no que a gente vai fazer de concreto
aqui no presente em concentrar-se em
como que a gente pode fluir não agora
hoje a gente fica se forçando a tá
sempre informado sempre estimulado no
ritmo que não é sustentável nem
produtivo a oms a denominou esse momento
e como uma infogma uma quantidade
excessiva de informações sobre um
problema que dificulta a solução ao
invés de ajudar a resolver é tanta gente
querendo saber qual é a próxima
tecnologia a próxima moda o próximo
assunto que a gente vive uma espécie de
ressaca do futuro mas essa não é a única
relação
e eu com tempo na mitologia da grécia
antiga por exemplo existe o impiedoso
cronos titã representava esse tempo do
relógio que tudo controla mas também
havia cá hiroshi cuja tradução é momento
oportuno um tempo sutil subjetivo que
representa essa nossa percepção
individual e intransferível da passagem
dos dias diante dessa sensação de que o
ano começou voando e tem que acelerar é
importante compreendermos que não
precisamos ou melhor não devemos seguir
esse mesmo compasso o
oi como que tá a sua relação com um
tempo enquanto a humanidade enfrenta
momentos de incerteza a grande pausa
parece que todo mundo quer conversar mas
por palavras não estão sendo o
suficiente parece que falta vocabulário
para lidar com tempos de incerteza por
exemplo antes de tudo isso você encarava
seus medos e desejos em relação a um
futuro que estava em rápida mudança só
que aí tudo mudou de novo e aí o que que
a gente faz com isso existe algum
caminho de volta aos tempos que a gente
conhecia como normalidade ou aqueles
dias vão ser para sempre encarados até
com algumas saudade mas então recebidos
como parte do problema que nos trouxe
até aqui essas perguntas que agora a
gente está se fazendo nos mostram que
vai ser necessário um novo tipo de
habilidade para respondê-las novos
códigos culturais novos comportamentos
novos combinados vai ser como aprender
um novo idioma que possa nos ajudar a
ver a realidade de uma nova maneira
sentir o que é a nossa realidade era o
que que ela tá sendo o que que ela pode
e aí
e eu acho que esse é um convite a gente
repensar a nossa relação com o tempo
como planeta para isso é preciso a gente
desenvolver algo que eu chamo de
inteligência temporal a linguiça lera
boroditsky diz que a nossa linguagem ela
moda a maneira como a gente percebe a
realidade com as palavras você usa para
descrever a sua relação com o tempo
aliás ela me lembra muito a personagem
principal do filme a chegada com a amy
adams a amy adams nesse filme ela também
faz uma personagem de uma linguiça que
faz parte de um time de pesquisadores
que está tentando desvendar um idioma
alienígena que parece a chave para a
gente perceber passado presente e futuro
de um jeito completamente novo mas
afinal o que que é o tempo o filósofo
grego aristóteles sugeria que o tempo é
a medida da mudança e eu passo que a
gente vai diferenciando o tempo a gente
compreende que o mundo vive um processo
de transformação que não para nunca
e ainda pelas lentes da ciência a
evolução do sugere que a melhor
gramática para gente pensar sobre o
mundo é a da mudança não há da
permanência não que somos mas o que
estamos nos tornando o mundo não é uma
coleção de coisas mas sim de eventos a
diferença entre coisas eventos é que as
coisas persistem no tempo enquanto os
eventos eles acontecem como a duração
limitada portanto eles são temporários
mas não ao que não seja relativo ao
tempo que não existem imerso no tempo
mesmo algo monumental como as pirâmides
do egito que já existem desde muito
tempo na história ela já foram sua bloco
de pedra muitos anos talvez essas pedras
ela já foram meteoro um dia talvez elas
vão ser somente areia
e elas são apenas um evento mais
duradouro que nós humanos mas ainda
assim um evento a gente navega mudança
pois tudo é temporal o filósofo george
santayana diz que aqueles que esquecem o
passado estão condenados a cometer os
mesmos erros o ivar ali sendo
historiador e futurista ele diz que a
gente precisa ter um olhar para esse
momento presente do século 21 a partir
do nosso passado e potencial futuro ele
alerta que a gente não quer pensar nisso
agora se o futuro da humanidade passasse
decidido na nossa ausência a gente não
vai estar exibido das consequências e
ele diz isso é muito injusto mas quem
disse que a história é justa o
neurocientista demonomanie diz que o
nosso cérebro é uma verdadeira máquina
do tempo nos transportamos por memórias
ou projeções enquanto a gente não tá no
momento agora o autor daniel pink
inclusive a escrever o que encontrar
esse time incerto de se ocupar
e ao invés de se preocupar é realmente
uma ciência porque as nossas vidas elas
são um fluxo interminável de decisões
não só de como fazer mas também quando o
psicólogo a philips em bardot ele disse
que cada um de nós dar uma atenção mais
positivo mais negativa para o seu
passado presente e futuro e que o melhor
mesmo é a gente encontrar balança entre
esses tempos mesma moeda do tempo atual
ela não é mais uma moeda mas sim o
próprio tempo quantas horas você teve
que trabalhar para pagar a última compra
importante que você fez entre essas
abordagens da filosofia física
psicologia economia entender as
interseções entre essas diferentes de
lentes é o meu trabalho e eu sinto agora
que algo necessário para a gente
desenvolver uma perspectiva mais
holística sobre a nossa relação com o
tempo eu vivo o tempo não fuso horário
diferente dos meus conterrâneos
brasileiros eu nasci em belém do pará
mas eu moro em amsterdã e aqui eu vivo
ao longo do ano a cerca de cinco
o futuro em relação ao brasil eu me
dedico a pesquisar estudar o tempo nesse
espectro completo eu lhe deram authors
que é o laboratório de estudos do tempo
onde a gente questiona como que as
pessoas entendem o tempo e se conectam
com ele individual e coletivamente
é para falar sobre a minha relação com o
tempo eu vou te apresentar esse artefato
chamado torce se eu desenhar ele numa
folha de papel você provavelmente vai
ver algo como um oito deitado ou alguns
oitos intercalados e aí vem as
referências sobre algo se repetindo
infinitamente algumas culturas chamavam
essa simbologia de ouroboros a serpente
que morde o próprio rabo no entanto a
nossa visão ela acaba limitada pelo fato
de que esse símbolo em duas dimensões
ele desenhada no papel representa algo
com mais dimensões nessa forma tornei
down em três dimensões a gente
compreende a que não estamos repetindo
essa mesma trajetória mas se explorando
todas as possibilidades em que múltiplos
passado se conectam a múltiplos futuros
e convergem e podem ser acessados pelo
mesmo ponto o único ponto o presente e
e como mudar a sua relação com o tempo
às vezes é preciso a gente abdicar de
tanta informação e manter o foco em
continuar se movendo no presente a gente
precisa prestar mais atenção no que está
mudando na gente e como que você tá se
sentindo deixar de lado se olhar
minucioso em relação aos detalhes do
passado do futuro e se concentrar no kit
liga ao próximo passo então é o seguinte
então depois você vai perceber quando
atingir esse modo porque navegadores e
exploradores de diversas áreas chamam
esse momento de fluxo sabe quando você
tá fazendo algo que você gosta muito aí
parece que o tempo voa depois disso
quando você escolher pensar sobre o
futuro antes disso que tal se voltar
duas vezes mais longe para o passado
para compreender como que você chegou
até aqui de novo no presente
e a gente sabe muito onde almeja chegar
mas o quanto que você conhece sobre o
seu ponto de partida esses dois tempos a
gente podem ter mais em comum do que
você imagina quando a gente se aprofunde
em todo o caminho percorrido até aqui é
que a gente alcance essa compreensão de
onde estamos hoje e aí transformamos um
momento presente no nosso ponto de
partida para nossa próxima viagem no
tempo vira tempos tardes de llorenç são
muitas as representações que aproximam
universo da ficção da nossa realidade
mas a melhor comparação que eu podia
fazer agora vem da série clássica cosmos
o caos sagan ele explorava o espaço e
tempo na sua nave the ship of
imagination no mundo real máquinas do
tempo elas são conceitos que passam a
existir a partir do momento em que a
gente as imagina eu acredito que essa é
a mais importante lição se máquinas do
tempo são conceitos teóricos inventados
para possibilitar av
e pelo tecido espaço temporal em frente
a sua ia viajar no tempo que tal não
encontrar somente um futuro mas olhar
esse futuro que que está na sua frente
se ele não falou que você esperava você
pode criar novos eu tenho eu quero
compartilhar um conto do escritor neil
gaiman um trechinho desse conto sobre o
personagem que eu gosto muito o destino
o destino é uma entidade que existe
desde o início dos tempos e ele vai
estar por aqui até o final o destino é
essa entidade que está acorrentada a
pela mão no livro e esse livro contém a
história de tudo que viveu vive e viverá
no entanto destino a cego todos os dias
pela manhã ele sai do seu castelo
acorrentado no seu livro e começa a
passear pelo seu jardim que é um
labirinto ao longo do dia ele faz curva
serra volta ele entra por caminhos
estreitos largos enfim ele segue o mais
longe possível ao fim do dia quando ele
olha para trás não tá mais ao labirinto
tudo que ele vê no seu jardim é uma
linha reta o seu caminho todos nós somos
como destino a gente não entendi porque
que a gente vai parar ali por quê que é
que elas são ou algo nos levou para
aquele fato para aquele sentimento aí a
gente atribui sua energias externas a
gente acha que alguém tomou essa decisão
por nós que nos fizeram entrar naquele
labirinto e quando a gente direciona o
nosso tempo e pensar sobre essas forças
externas que nos causam desconforto a
gente acaba criando essas entidades que
tomam escolhas por nós mas elas não
podem ser mais forte do que você de novo
é o seu caminho
as suas escolhas
e você pode criar o futuro que quiser a
partir dos próximos passos aqui no
presente se o próprio caminho e esse
futuro ele não precisa de pressionar a
fazer mais ser produtivo talvez seja
outra ideia daquele tempo que a gente
disse que pode fazer parte do problema
então a gente respira e lembra você só
precisa se você
é com essa visão mais ampla agora tá
ficando explícito na terra e também
dentro de nós os nossos problemas eles
são sistêmicos e um sistema as nossas
contribuições e necessidades elas também
devem considerar os benefícios e os
impactos coletivos para gente acordar
como uma mesma consciência planetária é
hora da gente mergulhar profundamente
nós mesmos encontrar ressonância um com
o outro vai aparecer mais escuro
possivelmente mas essas sombras elas são
projeções de si mesmos e se movendo em
direção a luxo o único caminho é através
não tem outra forma de lidar e é
necessário a gente tá aberto aqui pode
surgir do outro lado a gente está
aprendendo agora viajar no tempo juntos
em direção a esse próximo nível da nossa
consciência planetária eu acredito que
se você e eu estivermos em conexão com o
tempo ou seja consciente dos passados e
futuros que influenciam e são
influenciados pelo que somos pelo
e aqui a mais que a gente conseguir se
focar no presente e desenvolver essa
inteligência temporal a gente vai
aprender a navegar as mudanças juntos a
ressoar uma sociedade de criativa justa
ecológica a fluir no tempo para não
falar que eu sair daqui sem citar doctor
who falando de viagem no tempo nenhum de
nós sabe o que existe lá fora é por isso
que a gente continuar procurando então
mantenha a sua esperança vice em viagem
esperançosamente universo vai te
surpreender constantemente por isso eu
te recomendo a mergulhar nessa busca que
dá sentido à sua viagem aproveitá-la ao
máximo inventar sua máquina do tempo e
então criar o futuro que você deseja
alcançar um presente de cada vez isso é
o essencial agora você tá preparado para
começar
em boa viagem ce
[Música]